we can say with absolute certainty is uh
that the soldiers of Israel are not
going to be hiding among civilian
populations and using the populations as
Shields that is exactly what Hamas has
done it's exactly what the fight the
fighter terrorists of Hamas have done
it's their plan so you know there's also
an issue not only of proportionality but
of intentionality and the intention of
Hamas last week was to kill as many
innocent people as possible the
intention of Israel very clearly as has
been shown in many engagements is to
kill as few innocent people as possible
that difference might seem academic to
some people but in it lies everything